good day and welcome everyone
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia and please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my pleasure today and privilege to
welcome
dr daniel gardner professor of
physiology and biophysics from wild
cornell medical school
in new york city dan gardner has
cultivated a very
impressive career serving as the head of
the laboratory of neuroinformatics
and as professor of physiology and
biophysics at weill cornell
for many years now he has made enormous
contributions
to the synaptic biophysics underpinning
networks of neurons in aplasia
delivered resources for the exchange of
neuroscientific data
and examine the parallels between
biological and artificial neural
networks
he and members of his laboratory like to
ask the big questions
such as our neural circuits and the
computations they perform evolutionary
conserved
the answers to such questions may be
simplified as analyses of multi-neuron
recording
and inform new neuromorphic designs for
future artificial intelligence systems
dr garner examines new approaches to
explore this question
including a prod projected neuromorphic
neural networks
or n-cubed collaborative as well as
something called the
next cool virtual meeting which i'm
really interested to hear about dan
he has received numerous research
accolades and research support from
federal agencies
such as the national institutes of
health making vital contributions under
for example
the united states human brain project
that was
took place during the decade of the
brain um
as which is a kind of a precursor to the
brain initiative today
as well as to the european brain project
today's presentation from dan is
entitled do biological neural networks
perform
identifiable and verifiable canonical
computations
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube
if you are watching via youtube thank
you so much for joining us today
and also our specially selected 2020
2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr gardner via the chat feature of
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome dan thank you so
much we are really excited to hear your
lecture today
and professor van horn requested a
football
an analog so uh the uva quarterback
fades back throws and it's intercepted
by the big red cornell
now has the ball all right enough of the
football
analog now i'm going to be asking
this question but i'm not going to be
answering
yet so i'm going to propose
this neuromorphic neural network's
viewpoint
and neuromorphic neural networks with
the three n's
gives us the logo that you can see on
the right called
n cubed the ideas behind this come from
a very very large number of
colleagues at many many institutions
over many many years
too many to thank individually but i
especially
want to thank chuck stevens who's been
inspiring me
since 1971 and among the many people i
said who thought about this question
including chuck well we had a bunch of
us about
25 30 years ago now and what we thought
about it
and what resulted from it is no
ca noted on some of the following slides
and it's expanded later but first we
have a mandatory disclosure statement
my money comes only from federal grants
i'm a consultant occasionally to
[Music]
places in the u.s and the uk but i do
get significant
income from these books for instance the
principles of neuroscience
edited by candelar i get 25 cents
anytime one of you buys a copy
so i'm shamelessly going to be plugging
this book
throughout the the talk but the real
self-serving motivation not financial
is to encourage people in the data
sciences
in computational neuroscience and in the
machine
learning communities to think about the
question
of what computations are actually being
performed by
biological neural networks it's an
interesting question
to which we don't have an immediate
answer i'm going to begin with a
personal history
of neural networks and what they've
meant to me which gives you a sense
about
why i've been thinking about this
problem for so long
artificial neural networks for those of
you who don't work in the field were
first proposed
in ancient times in the 1940s
before people knew really anything about
how neurons and synapses work
and they were model objects
that had some of the properties that
people thought
neurons had they were a little bit like
logic gates that were on
or off and had multiple inputs and the
field didn't go very well
with the failure of what were called
perceptrons which it turned out couldn't
solve some simple
basic problems but then
uh in a classical past that was more
recent than that starting in the 1960s
these were made a little bit more
neuromorphic
especially as layering became possible
and an artificial neural neck that net
didn't have just
one or two layers but multiple layers
they were very
functional for simple problems elegantly
carried out but they had a very very non
neuromorphic backup which uh a method
for operation which i'll talk about very
briefly
called back propagation as a learning
rule
and as we will see back in this
classical past
a book that i and my friends put
together said
these might be more interesting if they
were more neuromorphic
in the present of course artificial
neural nets due to the growth and
processing power
of modern computers and due to much more
subtle and
interesting design of the artificial
neural nets
are can perform some extremely important
machine learning problems and so they
are enormously
functional today but they're
they they still cannot be one to one
matched
to what it is the brain does or how it
does it
the future perfect that i list down here
it would be really nice to leverage
our understanding of neurons and
circuits
to be able to build artificial neural
nets that were more neuromorphic and so
enhance machine learning
and it also might be useful to think
about some of the very clever ways
people are now
designing artificial neural nets as we
contemplate ways in which
the brain does what what it does
so going back this is supposed to be
historical this is 1987. i took a
ganglion i'd been working on
since the 1960s and i presented it
on the right as if it were a neural
network but of course it's biological
instead of being
arbitrary units emulated in
software or built with transistors and
capacitors
these were real identified neurons in a
real ganglion of the marine
snail aplisia and i presented this at
the
first international conference on neural
networks just when the field was
beginning
to get uh interesting and as you see it
was a
multi-layer network with defined
properties
also around then we had a meeting at
woods hole
in which we this is the fanciful design
for the t-shirt for the meeting
we thought we could link
biological and artificial neural
networks and look to see what their
commonality
was and you can see the red biological
neurons in the lower left and the
artificial
neural network units and connections in
the
upper right coming out of something
which is a meld
between a hippocampus and anaplysia
which were the subjects most often
studied
in this context in 1989 and you see this
was again
early this was the second volume of the
journal
neural networks i proposed a
testing and artificial neural network
learning rule
in a biological neural network it failed
spectacularly but it was still
interesting enough to be
published thereby underscoring the idea
that artificial and biological
neural networks had some real
fundamental differences
i was not the only one who began to
point this out
from the field of neurobiology you can
see some names
on the left the one up at the top
dr gordon shepherd published a paper in
which he pointed out some
very very significant differences
between biological
and artificial neural networks and other
investigators again in the 1980s listed
down below
on the left contributed to ideas for
this birth of
neuromorphic neural networks
even francis crick got into the act
and he published this commentary in
nature at the end of the 1980s
and you can see in the center the lower
part of the
center column he points out that
whatever it is artificial neural
networks do
the brain is different in almost every
respect
and that's francis quite elegantly
pointing out
how far one has to go to be able to talk
about to linking
the artificial and the biological
neural network so after this
this flurry of interest by
neurobiologists
in artificial nets and even interest in
the people who were purely developing
artificial nets
in the brain i got together some friends
and we ask this question is a network of
neurons really a neural network we noted
back then that
some features of artificial neural nets
and the biological networks of neurons
those are the bnns you've seen
resembled one another but others didn't
now my co-authors then were leveraging
a ns to understand bnns in the hope of
making
the artificial nets more neuromorphic
and more capable
but in the intervening 27 years now we
know much more
about biological nets and the
sophisticated artificial nets deep
convolutional nets
long short term memory nets have become
much more useful
so it's time to revisit this and that's
what i'm doing today
i'm gonna ask some artificial neural
network inspired
general questions about how biological
neural nets compute and up questions
about whether
evolution has conserved
some of the basics for this
back in 1993 my colleague eberhard fetz
pointed out in the context of a
biological net
how artificial neural nets did things
in terms of excitatory and
inhibitory connection matrices
which had variable strengths something
that sounds
very much like the way biological nets
work the problem that we stressed in
1993
was that artificial neural nets and
their properties
are summarized by the diagrams
on this slide and the equations that
accompany them
they can biological networks work
a little bit like artificial nets
according to the scheme on the left
that is they take in inputs they summit
there's a non-linear transform
this is then transformed along an axon
in a forward direction from
cell body to termini and then
there are connections made on still
other
neurons and everything on the left is
sort of plausible in a biological
context but on the right artificial nets
require
back propagation of errors
and multi-layer back propagation
or local tuning of synapse strength
by global error signals or error signals
many many
layers further up these were viewed
quite skeptically
in 1993. as i'll show later on the
skepticism
has been a little bit reduced but the
basic back propagation scheme
shown here on the right which i'm not
going to go into
in detail seemed very different from
the way we thought neurons worked in
1993.
now we should remember that
evolution works evolution
designs neural networks neural networks
work
and i'm also going to stress the fact
that neural networks
process or compute information
of course they evolved to be able to
learn
but what they are learning to do is to
perform
pattern recognition to be able to
recognize say
a piece of fruit from a predator to
classify
many many different inputs to make
decisions
on the back of it and to form action
patterns as a result of this
we know that the networks in our brain
and even
in other animals and even in other parts
of our nervous system like the spinal
cord
or the eye may be optimized for specif
specific features of the real world
because evolution found that to be
efficient
so things like locality low
dimensionality
relevance novelty those
things may get more attention from
nervous systems than
others some biological neural networks
and by this i mean
small networks composed of a
manageable number of neurons some of
them do things that we can understand
integrators for instance we can
understand comparators
some use maximum entropy strategies for
efficient coding
but in general we don't know how they
work that is we don't know what they're
computing
or how they're computing it and that's
motivation for this work because
if we did know that then perhaps the
ways
in which our brains efficiently do this
computation and reduce error
making use of only the mechanisms that
the laws of physics and evolution make
available to them
could that enhance the design of
artificial
neural networks especially artificial
neural networks that
we want to design to solve problems that
are
similar or isomorphic to the ones that
our
brains solve now i use the word
computation and we probably don't think
of our nervous systems
as computing and we may think of
arithmetic for instance is something
that's very very artificial
that we can do but certainly our nervous
systems didn't evolve to do
and so i'm just pointing out that many
lower organisms in addition to people
seem to be able to do computations
there are reports that that pigeons can
behaviorally show subtraction
understand subtraction and modify their
actions in a trained situation
according to carrying out even something
as simple as an insect
honeybees can can use tags for something
that's
greater than what they've one greater
than what they've seen before or one
fewer than what they've seen before and
they can again
modify their actions by this
so so nervous systems even what we used
to call
primitive nervous systems seem to be
able to
actually do computation and of course
i'm using the term
in a much larger sense
than that i'm using it to mean
processing information
but i find it striking that that that
computation itself
counting is something that nervous
systems seem to be able to do
now here's a very famous slide that most
of you
are likely to have seen before
and this shows from the laboratory from
dan yemen's working in the laboratory of
jim dicarlo at mit
some years ago this shows similarities
between the circuitry that does
processing
in the ventral stream of primate
vision and that's shown up on the top
and an artificial neural network
trained to recognize people
from photographs of those people
and what's striking about the
similarities is that in each case
these are composed of simple units
neurons up above
and artificial units down below
there is a feed-forward organization
to these there are non-linear
transforms and although the two are very
very different
what is striking about this is that it's
several
layers of both the real biological net
and the artificial net there are
individual
units and sets of units that seem to
have the same
selectivity for the very same pictures
in the very same way in different ways
at different levels and the maturity
of being able to recognize an individual
based on information that is processed
across the multiple
layers that also progresses
in both the biological net and the
artificial net
so this reminds us that there are enough
similarities
between what a multi-layer system
can do to make this an interesting and
important question
even though the behavior at the
individual levels
is very very different for the
biological and for the artificial system
so let's ask ourselves that's enough of
an introduction
let's ask ourselves what is it that
biological
neural networks are computing well i
don't know
these are unanswered questions these
are very reductionist questions these
are the simplest way
i can express it and one question is
what is it that brains
are computing then how if you know that
how are those computations
actually implemented by neural circuitry
and what to me is the most interesting
potential question is the third one
do these computations form a small
canonical set that is
if evolution has conserved as it has the
basic properties of
neurons synapses glia
across the animal kingdom as well as the
goals that nervous systems produce
is the next level the circuit level also
conserved and is there a small canonical
set
of circuits or computations performed by
this circuit
that one can identify comparatively by
looking at different parts
say of a single nervous system like the
cortex
or by looking across nervous systems
even perhaps to some of those honey bees
and aplisia
that i mentioned earlier and then
there's a fourth
unanswered question which is neurons
are cells glia are cells they make use
of neurochemicals
and which of the many many properties
that characterize
these cells that happen to be neurons
are actually the ones that are
essential for computation
there's another question not listed here
which i i may touch on
briefly which is how do biological nets
solve the curse of dimensionality
because they have
far more parameters to adjust than
artificial neural nets do and i think
these really do
qualify as some of those elusive
principles
of neural science that we would all like
to be able to work out
so are these principles that i just
showed you on the last slide are they
evolutionarily
conserved here you see the very very
famous levels from pat churchland
and terry sanofsky from the central
nervous system up at the top
down through successively finer layers
to get
down to the individual molecules
at the bottom and we should look
at what it is that evolution has
conserved
okay sweeping up from the bottom
molecularly there's a very small number
of essential proteins
and other molecules that are not
sometimes some of them are specific to
neural function
some of them are available for general
cell biology
but tend to be used in the same way
in nervous systems throughout the animal
kingdom
looking up one layer there's a very
small number of excitatory and
inhibitory
synapses there are very very few
neurotransmitters and there's a small
conserved number conserved in sequence
and in structure
of membrane proteins that help carry out
synaptic transmissions
up above neurons look very very
different from one another in structure
but the number of basic types is very
very small
enormous quantitative variation in the
properties
of the neurons electrical anatomical
functional but but really they're
qualitatively they're all quite similar
and the neurochemistry
is very very similar so but
in between in between at the network at
the layer of the network or the circuit
are the circuits really the micro
circuits and the computations
and transforms that they mediate are
those
similarly evolutionarily conserved
is there a small number of canonical
types
up at the top which you can still see
the goals
of the nervous system the componentry
whatever it is that nervous systems do
in the life of organisms that's
similarly conserved
by evolution so it's an intriguing
question
to see if this mid layer is also
something that ends up with a small
number of
canonical properties and to repeat we're
talking both
about the computations or transforms
that are performed
and also the circuitry that performs
them
so there is some complexity there
certainly is some variability especially
to within the networks but what is it
that might be neuromorphically essential
this what's common to nervous systems
what's characteristic
of nervous systems that might inform our
thinking
when we start asking these questions
well nervous systems have
complex connectivity it's more complex
than that of
artificial neural nets which tend to be
very very simple there are three or four
different ways in which they come
in which they are connected to one
another
but in the the brain in brains
in nervous systems the connectivity is
sparse
as well as complex there obviously are
micro circuits that are characteristic
of different structures of the brain
that the circuitry looks different but
perhaps the functions that are being
performed
are are are not so different we need to
study that
there is extensive top-down signaling
in almost all nervous systems in
addition to the bottom-up ones we tend
to think of
from sensation through computation
to action now brains
have many many more neurons like
artificial neural networks
artificial neural networks these days
tend to be deep with many many layers
but the brains tend to have fewer layers
than functional artificial neural
networks these days
some of them are like wide rather than
deep
artificial nets a subset of the top and
different parts of the brain
and different uh different nervous
systems
tend to be wider or deeper again perhaps
because they're carrying out the
functions in different ways
most artificial neural networks make
very little use
of inhibition but the brain
does require inhibition and what's
fascinating is within a structure
there's always a characteristic
percentage of neurons that are
inhibitory
but this percentage varies widely it's
two percent say in something like the
cerebellum
up to 50 percent in some other areas
20 in the cortex and the types of
inhibitory mechanisms and the effects
they perform
on on neurons vary greatly those are
again
tuned biological nets
brains are very very stochastic
that is if you look trial to trial
in an artificial neural network if you
feed it the same input
you're very likely to get the same
output each time
this is not true of brains at the
cellular or
synaptic level and that stochasticity
is fascinating and may itself have a
computational role
and of course biological networks make
use of
plastic synapses that is the efficacy of
the synapse
changes over time now artificial nets
have plastic synapses or variable
strength connectivity
but that's usually only modified in a
training period
and once training is complete those tend
to be
fixed and maintained this is not true of
the brain
and and that's for the reason that we
and our brains
have to keep learning at all times
and there is no time when we can expect
the brain to be
stable and fully wired up
with no changes in the future
now any system that learns has to have
learning rules any system that computes
has to have algorithms to perform the
computations
but again these are things that
surprisingly are
imperfectly understood and we really
need to get
better analyses of these
that in in order to carry out these
questions
so how to begin well if
there's a conserved property of nervous
systems that's useful
for computation then perhaps we can ask
what's common to all nervous systems
and here's a list of some of the things
this expands on some of the stuff i said
earlier
nervous systems fire irregularly
the synapses are stochastic and plastic
essentially all nervous systems process
information in two different ways
through digital spikes or action
potentials
and through analog or graded
postsynaptic potentials
and they all have in between these two
a non-linear transform and so one
question is
is there a neuromorphic computational
advantage
to this there certainly is for
artificial
neural nets because artificial neural
nets that don't have a non-linearity
built into them
at every level at every layer
don't work very well one thing that's
striking to a cell biologist
is that neurons post-development
are very very long-lived is this
persistence
essential non-neuronal cell types aren't
like that they turn over
perfectly happily so your red blood
cells or your bone or your skin
turns over quite frequently without any
change but for some reason neurons
don't what's the advantage there
also neural circuitry leverages very
high
fan in and fan out the selective
balancing of inhibition i mentioned
a moment ago and so this forms a dynamic
assembly but it's it's stable at any
given moment
and it's really quite remarkable that
evolution can provide
dynamism and constant change while
keeping the system
stable another characteristic
of nervous system is that an enormous
amount of processing is done by
local nets and the local nets
process information but they're
modulated or coordinated
by long fibers from other
local nets and i list here some of the
things that may be made possible
by this but i want to stress that the
connectivity
the long distance connections come from
the bottom up
which seems logical but they also come
from the top
down in the nervous system and they're
also
lateral and without this condistant
connectivity
constantly informing the local
processing net of how it should be doing
its computation
it doesn't work and again neurons vary
in their connectivity
their excitatory inhibitory balance how
they integrate and so on
so brains do not have a single kind
of processing unit okay
so these are some possible candidates
for computational essentials
but there are also properties that are
common to all neurons
that are cell biological they're
important for function
but they're unlikely to be computational
essentials
and i list some of the basic cell
biology
without this the neurons will die but
these are not computational
these are just keeping the system
working so it can make use of those
comp special computational properties
and there's also a lot of diversity
and among nervous systems and i'm going
to very briefly show this because this
is not an audience of neuroscientists
different synapses and the neurons
that make the synapses are tuned in
different ways the structure
of neurons vary and the circuits are
tuned
what the synapses do where on the cells
the synapses are formed
all of these things are quite specific
the dendrites of the nervous system are
quite specialized those
are the inputs and i think these are
drawings from santiago ramone cajal the
great spanish neuroanatomist
assembled by my friends kristen harris
and john
fiala to show differences here
and the dendrites are the parts that are
shown in the gray arrow and above and a
little bit below
and you see on the left they can be very
very small and selective
and take tight inputs from the immediate
area
in the middle this hippocampal pyramidal
cell with an extensive dendritic tree
is actually sampling the space in which
it's located
it's only getting input from about three
to
five percent of the neurons that it
could reach
with those dendrites so it's quite
selective as to the connections
it's making and on the right the
cerebellar purkinje cell
has this giant sheet that can get
hundreds
of thousands of inputs and this one is
indiscriminate in the sense that it
makes a connection to
every fiber that comes anywhere near it
so the way in which neurons compute
depends on the circuits in which they
are placed
and here are some classic examples on
the left this is the
canonical uh excitatory
cell arrangement in cerebral cortex
showing how pyramidal cells make
connections to
other pyramidal cells and different
parts
in the middle the cerebral cortex has
several kinds of
interneurons and these different
interneurons are shown making specific
connections on parts of pyramidal cells
or of other interneurons
on the right the circuitry in the
cerebellum and i showed you the purkinje
cell
dendrites just a slide or so ago this
combines both
excitatory and inhibitory
cells and it's a much simpler circuit
but it's one whose purpose still remains
incompletely understood
and there are several different
candidates for the computation
being performed by this
so one question
that we also need to think about if
we're going to be looking for canonical
connections
is what isn't common to all nervous
systems
so given this diversity there are
features found in some nervous systems
but not in others
if there are reductionist computational
essentials they're unlikely
to be one of the ones listed on this
slide
so we do not have all-purpose neurons or
one
fixed balance for excite excitation and
inhibition
nor is it merely an emergent property of
having large
numbers of neurons nor is a neuron a
simple atomistic
object like in artificial neural
networks
because neurons vary widely and some are
quite complex
single neurons and able to process
information
and neuronal firing is highly variable i
totally told you to a fixed stimulus
the nervous system never responds
exactly the same way like heraclitus's
river
and here is a stereotyped stimulus
being delivered and these are recordings
from
six electrodes for the ten different
trials here and you'll notice that at
for each of the six electrodes
the ten different trials show very very
different
results now this variability
may be intentional there may be
deterministic
input that we don't know about it may be
noise the very
presence of noise may aid calculation
we don't know now
here's a fundamental problem that we
have
we can record from thousands
of neurons in biological neural networks
this is already 10 years old
and that was showing reliable recording
of 200 neurons or so
but these multi-electrode techniques and
these arrays have gotten even better
and we can now record from thousands and
thousands
of neurons but we can't predict the
firing of thousands of neurons
if we understood what i said was the
problem how do
nervous systems compute and what is the
circuitry that does the computation
then we could predict the operation
of the nervous system now this is easy
for electrical circuits with
thousands of components but it's not
true for more than a handful of neurons
and even for those it's not true for
more than a handful of
seconds also we can simulate
exemplar nervous systems artificial ones
resembling the brain with very fixed
tuned parameter values but this doesn't
work for real specific
neurons or circuits and this is because
individual neural and synaptic
parameters
vary in ways we can't easily measure and
there are too many of them to model
exactly and this raises another question
the brain developmentally selects and
tunes parameters other than synaptic
strength but we don't know how
the slow process during development is
the brain's first
credit assignment problem credit
assignment being the problem of knowing
what to change deep within a network to
get a desired result to learn
and then tuning individual synaptic
strength during
adult life classical plasticity is the
brain's second
credit assignment problem so how do
biological nets perform these two
credit assignment problems neural
networks
need to do it to function to stabilize
and to tune
synaptic weights any neural network does
artificial neural networks do it most
famously by multi-layer back
propagation but i already told you
that's non-neuromorphic
and many groups have listed proposed
alternatives to these again here are the
two
different properties
i also should mention some clinical
relevance
the developmental selection form of
credit assignment is disrupted
and the result for that are some very
early auto developmental
disorders secondly there are the
individual
tuning that is altered in later onset
neurodevelopment
disorders that show up say between the
ages of 17
and 25. as a fascinating footnote at the
bottom
there's one transcription factor called
mecp2 which manifests
early as a gain of function defect for
that first
problem but as a loss of function it
affects the second
problem here so the same molecule may be
involved
in both of these so here are some of
those alternatives
i i talked about here you know the
biological neural network local circuits
may be
pre-programmed for plasticity there's
something called
synapse tagging that i won't have time
to get to
is there a local process or a global
excitatory inhibitory balance that can
do this
do astrocytes receive global signals
and adjust local some people have
proposed a solution called
neuroevolution for this i don't have the
time to go into them
and i'm going to zoom through the slides
that present it
here's a question of a neuron
that makes two different connections the
neuron is shown in red between two green
neurons here
and in fact tagging of one
output site rather than another can mean
that that is functional and will change
with a global signal whereas the other
one
won't there is in
uh the possibility of glial
cells the glial cells are shown here in
blue
the neurons are shown in this tan
color presynaptic endings on the top a
little bit of the
postsynaptic neuron below for each of
these four
diagrams and the neurotransmitters in
this case glutamate the excitatory gaba
the inhibitory neurotransmitters
are recycled for further synaptic
transmission through the glial cells
and glial cells may make more
connections than the neurons
and may receive signals to control
synaptic strength and i'm going to skip
over this which shows basically the same
sort of thing
we saw below so many groups have
proposed
various neuromorphic suggestions linking
artificial and biological neural nets
for credit assignment
other people have reported properties of
bnns that might be computationally
useful
or essential and as these examples
scroll majestically by as we go from the
upper layers down to the lower layers
this simply shows that there are a large
number of
potential candidates for
an evolutionarily conserved mechanism
mechanisms for computation and
mechanisms
for uh for um
for credit assignment i want to just
talk about
one very briefly uh the first one here
which is shown in red
this is recent work from chuck stevens
lab
at the salk showing that in several
different sensory systems in mammals and
in vertebrates
maximum entropy coding encodes
and decodes the largest number of
possible
choices that the nervous system has to
make
given the number of cells used for the
task
it's highly efficient my enthusiasm
means that i've run
late so i can't talk about it but here's
a credit assignment one
this expands on what i saw about
astrocytes
even including the control of
non-linearities in addition to the
amount of
neurotransmitter that's been advanced by
a couple of labs
i'm not going to talk about the fly odor
coding but i refer you
to recent work from this the lab of cf
stevens for this
instead i want to finish by telling you
about
the encubed project here
for looking for neuromorphic computation
now i pulled these five books from my
bookshelf
six books sorry uh five which
can do something and the sixth which
can't they all present circuits
but the one on brain micro circuits
gordon shepard and sten grilners the
arrows pointing to it
is not like the others it's the only one
where the anatomy the function and the
connectivity of many micro circuits are
laid out in beautiful detail
but not the computations they perform
why
is this so why
can the electronic circuit books do this
they can take the circuit on the left
and predict from that the function
as shown on the right or they can take
the pattern of activity shown on the
right and reverse
engineer the circuit that's doing that
called system identification
so they can do that but we can't
so are neural circuits identifiable in
the same way
as it says here electronic ones are
the third bullet point says that there
are a few
neural circuit operations or
calculations i mentioned one or two of
these earlier
weighted summation leaky integration
gated uh various patterns of inhibition
lateral inhibitions surround inhibition
uh
isomorph a non-isomorphic anisomorphic
surround inhibition which gives you
direction sensitivity
response sharpening from surround
inhibition
gain control winner take all
persistence of a signal delay lines
attractors even some predictors
non-linear analog to digital and
digitalog to anal digital to analog
converters we know neural circuits do
this
but if we're thinking in terms of
electronics where are say the half
adders or where is something that can
demodulate a signal from a carrier
now one possibility is we can't detect
other than the elementary
building blocks and find the serious
functional circuits
well maybe stochastic firing is a com
confound
and that makes input output analyses
hard to do
now one question is are neurons just
too diverse or too specialized to form
canonical circuits
all neurons are variants of only a few
basic
types and this is also true of
electronic components
so on the left is a listing of some
hippocampal
inhibitory neurons there are many
different kinds
shown there but they all perform the
same basic
function and this is just like the many
mosfets on the right
not quite interchangeable you can't plug
one in for the other
but all working the same way and all
covered
by the same uh symbol
some people say you know i'm advocating
consideration of an and search for
potential
evolutionarily conserved mechanisms but
maybe
that isn't the case maybe all the
circuits and computations are just
evolutionarily ad hoc and there is no
general circuitry nor canonical uh no
general theory nor canonical circuitry
evolution just builds ad hoc and it's
different
everywhere or computability may just be
an emergent property of
any circuitry that sums and transforms
so do we care some people say they don't
care whether it does it or not i care
and and so at uh the society for
neuroscience symposium about a year and
a quarter ago
where i introduced this topic i asked
the
100 or so attendees what they thought
and the voting among the neuroscientists
was 10 to 1
in favor of canonical circuits or
algorithms
so i want to wrap up with what i want to
do about this
many different labs work on this problem
but what i'm proposing is not something
that any single
lab can do to answer a general question
requires collegial parallel efforts by
many investigators using different
techniques
in several preparations and so what we
need to do
is to get together we're going to be
planning a multi-day neuro match
meeting of this to get this started
and we'll know that this is going to
work if at least half the people we
invite say well i'm already doing that
or already solved that problem
and then once we get people aboard
this what we want to be able to do is to
encourage
funding agencies to support adding
explorations of computational
capabilities
to the ongoing research from many of
those labs and those different
preparations and of course because we're
forward thinking we think all data code
algorithms and so on should be open
source and freely available
and this would help launch this field
and allow
other funding agencies to decide so
you're hearing something that's just at
the beginning
of a new idea and here are some of the
people who contributed to this
at symposia in 2019
and in 2020
for this of course the sfn symposium was
not just a few months ago it was a year
and a few months ago
because we didn't have one meeting in in
2020.
but all of these people contributed to
this and i'd like to thank those groups
who've collegially
helped build this idea along and now i'm
ready for questions
dan thank you so much for that uh
overview
of neural networks and what kind of
computing
they do and this is just clearly a
an interesting challenge which is it's
interesting from the context of data
science which is you know so often
deals with thinking about how to
statistically analyze
uh systems for example um in this case
you're really trying to take it to the
next level say
perhaps using the knowledge you gain
through a data science
approach to inform how you might create
synthetic models of biological systems
so this is
very pleased that you were able to
present this to us
one of the things which one of our our
uh participants kind of
raises a question i have the same
question myself is that
very often these neural networks the the
whole the goal it's claimed is oh
pattern recognition we want to be able
to recognize patterns
but really is that what we really want
to do all the time or
really are we trying to understand the
foundational properties of these
biological systems and i think
you're a fan of the latter and not the
former and i also want to kind of ask in
that same context
is as a result of that do these
artificial versus biological
neural networks do they pass something
resembling
any kind of a touring test that we're
aware of
well okay so so so the the first
question is
is well people say that these networks
are good
at pattern recognition or pattern
identification
because that's how they test them right
and and i think something that isn't i
didn't say
explicitly but i probably should is
what you think a system is doing depends
upon what question you asked it
but i don't know what it was that
evolution
designed the system to do we know what
we can do
but we don't know how but we we can do
it from introspection we can do it by
observing
others by either others of our species
or experimental
animals but that doesn't tell us what's
actually being done
and and the purpose of say of of having
a
uh a group of different investigators
working
in different preparations is to say
for someone to say well i think that
what the the micro circuit that i'm
doing
is computing is the following and can
somebody
test out that idea on their preparation
and see if that's something similar to
it
so that's how we start looking for what
might be
a small number of canonical
computations so i don't know what it's
what it's there for now the other
question uh
you weren't specific about the
artificial versus biological and
and the touring test i i showed an
example the classic ones
are unfortunately ones that are used for
pattern recognition
and for pattern discrimination those are
the ones that
mimic the visual system and and
and that is a form of turing test in
that
you can give a primate or you can give
an artificial neural net the same inputs
and allow each one will make the same
mostly the same selections and
discriminations
so are you willing to accept that as as
a touring test
uh what we're talking about of course is
something at a very simple
fundamental level and so
i think the turing test you want
is to be able to identify
a a computation that you think
a a network of 80 or 100 neurons
is performing and then you should be
able to feed it inputs and predict what
the
output is that is not quite a turing
test that is a test
of a model and i think that's as close
as you're going to get
when we're talking about phenomena at
this level
you know it's another thing is as you
were presenting and talking about some
of these kind of foundational building
blocks the the the rules or the
the kind of the behaviors of these
neurons and these systems i'm reminded
that it's been 50 years since conway's
game of life
kind of emerged on the scene and many of
us who are of a certain age
monkeyed around with those simple rules
between
neighboring cells in a network to try to
produce interesting
behaviors out of very simplistic rules
and i'm kind of curious
if some of those mean not of course the
same rules but
are would you hope that a similar sort
of you know
three five rules might be underlying
what we see in very complex systems well
yeah it's even better than that because
conway's game of life is a special case
and a late special case of cellular
automata
exactly and the cellular automata that
were first
looked at in the 1940s and early 1950s
by johnny van neumann and
others were they were consciously
thinking
about nervous systems and computing
at the same time and they wanted to do
their their first look at cellular
automata
was actually to build a touring machine
and i think they they had one with what
was it 39
rules and and that could compute
absolutely anything
and so they could build a touring
machine out of cellular automata
but again this was a time when nothing
was known
about the brain in the terms that we
know it now
and the the synthesis between
cellular automata computers and
nervous systems doing processing has
been with
us for what is now uh almost
70 years so so the
the the links are intriguing the
game of life is just a very very simple
thing this
it would be great fun if we discovered
that some of neural development
i mean if you think about this in terms
of an electronic
analogy the brain is wired up
from a parts kit these days electronic
devices are all
three-dimensional and you lay down
transistors and capacitors and resistors
in multiple layers which is similar to
the way
neurons go in the brain our excitatory
uh inputs come from the neurons come
from the subventricular zone
or inhibitory ones fly in from the
ganglionic
eminence just at the right time from a
different
parts bin and then they assemble
themselves and that's part of that first
credit assignment
problem that i talked about here
so there are always going to be
engineering questions it would be
fun if some of the principles used
for those inhibitory neurons to make
some of those connections
could be shown to be in some ways
isomorphic to some of the rules that
cellular automata use i have no idea if
that's true or not
but it shows you how thinking about the
brain from this perspective
can cause different people and i hope
somebody listening to this is
is taking notes saying that would be an
interesting problem to work on
how this can inform uh what you know
what what work should be done
one final question for you dan what role
does data science play
in achieving some of the goals of what
you described for
it's essential and and i should have
made this explicit
because when i talk about people saying
making comparisons from laboratory to
laboratory that requires the easy
exchange of data you can say this is
what my
neuron does my my neural network
does and does your neural network do
this
and that's not possible without
effortlessly
taking the algorithm and the data
extending it
and and you and i jack worked on this
years ago for the human
brain project when we tried doing some
of the first
fundamental rules for data exchange
for the neurosciences and and without
that sort of effort what i propose would
not be possible
well dan thank you so much for sharing
this is so fun
this is so thought provoking i could go
all day
but uh i want to thank you so much for
uh sharing this with us so this was
really inspiring and i
hope that our audience was inspired as
well
um thank you so much uh thank you
everybody for who
joined us and um enjoy your weekend
we'll see you next week thank you
thanks so long all